A striking in nearly unique feature
of human reproduction is menopause
and it's puzzling if evolution
actually runs on reproductive success.
Then why should an
organism stop reproducing?
It has five suggested functions and
we'll go through them in some detail.
The first is the idea that it is for
the safety of the last offspring.
It's the mother hypothesis.
The second is that the grandmother could
help her daughter because she's being
released from taking
care of her own babies.
The third idea is that daughters
in law are out competing.
The target female.
A fourth is that it's a byproduct
of quality control of oocytes,
and the fifth idea is that is
the result of self domestication,
so let's step through those.
Yeah.
Menopause is rare in mammals
and it's derived in humans.
Our closest relatives do not
have menopause. Chimpanzees,
Bonobos and gorillas do not.
We'll see some data on that in a moment.
There are two citations to Wales that
do have menopause and they have clothes
enduring maternal offspring interactions,
pilot whales and the killer whales.
They are rather difficult to study.
Okay,
we're going to now look at four panels
and what I want to stress in these panels
is the patterns of
survival and reproduction.
So the blue is fertility,
the red is survivorship,
this is chimpanzees,
and what you can see is
that chimpanzee survival,
this is the percentage which uh,
are surviving from birth is dropping.
Chimpanzees are starting to reproduce
at about 10 to 12 years of age and they
continue to reproduce right through
until they're about 50 years old.
So they reproduce right
up to the end of life.
And if we take the chimpanzee reproduction
curve and put it over here in black,
that's just the same
curve brought over here.
This is births per female per year and
we plot onto it the reproduction curves
for two human Honda Hunter gatherers,
the corn and the ACI.
We see that in broad outline.
They're pretty similar.
We start reproducing a little bit later,
but we stopped reproducing
it about the same age,
about 45 to 50 however,
when we look at the survival curves,
in this case for the Kong and for the ACI,
the survival is in red.
The reproduction is in blue.
What we see is that in cases there are
several decades of survival after less
reproduction,
so this is menopause kicking in
at the end of reproductive life,
but with a couple of decades of life
potential life lift. After that,
this means that we compare
humans to chimpanzee patterns.
Menopause results from an evolve
change in survival, not fertility.
There were five hypotheses
for this mother, grandmother,
reproductive conflict,
byproduct. In self domestication,
we'll start with the mother hypothesis.
It
posits that menopause evolved is part of
the terminal reproductive investment of
mothers to ensure that children would
not be endangered by the increasing risk
with age that the mother has of dying
while giving birth. In other words,
make sure that the mother survives
to take care of her last child.
Okay.
It makes some sense,
but it's also clear that mothers now
survive longer than their parental care
would be needed,
and theoretical models indicate that the
effects of maternal mortality are not
large enough to make this
a standalone explanation,
so it might have an element of
truth to it, but it's insufficient.
Yeah.
The grandmother hypothesis
is that menopause evolve
to reduce the increasingly
compromised reproduction of grandmothers
so that they could gain more fitness by
helping their offspring
raised their grandchildren.
Okay.
So this is an intergenerational transfer
from the old to the young and that
could support selection to extend
the post reproductive period. So the,
the idea here is that survival actually
evolve to be longer in order to allow
grandparents to take
care of grandchildren.
Yeah.
Evidence on this is mixed.
Sometimes the presence of grandmothers
improves the survival of grandchildren in
some societies that does not.
The third idea that's out there is
the reproductive conflict hypothesis.
And this is couched in
terms of kin selection,
mothers in law or more related to their
own offspring oh 0.5 than to those of
their daughters in law oh 0.25 whereas
daughters in law or unrelated to their
mother-in-law's offspring
zero relationship and are
more related to their own
whole 0.5.
So daughters in law would be under greater
selection to when a conflict over any
resource used in reproduction that
could select against Rick continued
reproduction in older women
in a small scale society.
Yeah.
The biproduct hypothesis says that
menopause didn't evolve itself.
It is the byproduct of selection
for quality control of o sites.
So if you have high quality
control early in life,
it's screening out lot of ohs sides
and producing high quality offspring.
If their fitness outweighs what you might
gain from having more offspring late
in life who might be of lower quality
because the screen wasn't as good,
then menopause could
evolve as a byproduct.
This effect would be stronger if the
aging of the quality control filters means
that offspring born later or more likely
to be defective. In fact, they are.
We know that
the idea here is that menopause occurs
when women run out of Oh sides and they
run out of those sites because they're
discarding defective ones for quality
control.
Now the self domestication hypothesis
has elements of both the grandmother
hypothesis and the quality
control if offices.
It posits that post reproductive life
resulted from improvements in survival
caused by soulfulness social cooperation
and the agricultural revolutions.
So that's when we domesticate it
ourselves once it then existed.
So once there was a post
reproductive survival,
it's existence made possible selection
then to modify the behavior of those post
reproductive individuals to help
grandchildren if they were around and they
could be made useful by changing their
behavior a little bit then and that
improved fitness and got more
genes into future generations,
then that would be operated on.
So the idea here is that post reproductive
life came first as a consequence of
culture and then grand
parental behavior was selected.
So that combines the
grandmother hypothesis and the
quality control hypothesis.
These five hypotheses are
not mutually exclusive.
So to summarize on menopause,
it probably evolved for a combination
of reasons that include these,
the mother hypothesis.
Mothers need to survive long
enough to care for the last child,
the grandmother hypothesis.
There comes a point in aging females at
which they can get more out of helping
their daughters than out
of reproducing themselves.
The reproductive conflict hypothesis,
the daughters in law or less closely
related to their mother-in-law's offspring
than they are to their own and should be
more strongly selected to win conflicts
over resources.
The quality control hypothesis,
which is that menopause is a byproduct
of quality control for Gametes.
That,
and it occurs when women run out of
oocytes and the self domestication
hypothesis,
which is that the first post reproductive
life appeared when cultural evolution
improved survival, and then selection
shaped grand parental behavior.